[Music]
well rachel i was right and i was wrong
oh
i'll tell you i'll take both of these
yeah you're good
i was a hundred percent wrong i thought
that washington would never actually do
anything except blow v8 and
carry on about
student loan forgiveness
the president biden is announcing today
that he is actually doing it
i'm guessing that the fa that he's doing
that with an executive order and i'm
guessing there will be some legal
challenges to that because i don't know
if he has the legal right to do that
with an executive order i'm not a
constitutional expert we'll see about
all that but he is doing it the thing i
was right about was i was 100 sure that
this ridiculously failed presidency was
going to do a hail mary going into the
midterms and i knew i told you guys i've
told you guys over the air here several
times in the past several weeks that he
was going to do an announcement this
week the week before the student loan uh
interest rate uh
forgiveness yeah the repayment was going
to restart on august 31st i was 100 sure
he was going to extend that and announce
something
about some kind of student loan
forgiveness i said that was going to
happen i also said that when it happened
it would not amount to anything that it
would be a bunch of political crap and
when you read the fine print that
nothing would happen but this appears to
actually have some teeth so it has
something welcome what's wrong about
that and as we're speaking right now
though the press conference has not gone
live we've just seen what the white
house is releasing the details well
they've released some of it yes but i'm
curious here in the next few hours when
the press conference what what actually
the details of it and what ends up
happening because
it appears it appears that if you have
that
up to ten thousand dollars will be
forgiven if you make less than 125 000 a
year in student loans
it appears that public loans not private
public not private
um and one guy already tweeted and said
my mortgage is now self-identifying as a
student line so just to just let you
know um but
[Laughter]
not working but i'm sorry uh but the
second thing that happened was uh if
you're if you're a pell grant recipient
uh meaning that you were in there on a
uh you were struggling you're at the
poverty level or whatever uh when you
went into school uh then you get up to
twenty thousand dollars forgiven if you
make less than 125 000 a year yeah this
appears to affect about 20 million
student loans
uh i mean student loan uh holders yeah
and so out of the 43 million so it's
pretty substantial so here's our take on
this
we've been talking about it around here
for a couple days because we you know
they telescope that this was coming
telegraph this was
coming in a sense
um
that
number one first and foremost if you are
a ten thousand dollar student loan
person and you make less 125 000 and
this this is getting ready to be
forgiven
uh we're happy for you
we want good things for you
we're happy
for you we we're glad you got we want
you out of debt as quickly we want you
to get out of debt and we're happy for
you as individuals we're also
simultaneously
angry on behalf of the people who paid
off their loans and uh feel screwed and
you know why they feel screwed is
because they got screwed that's why they
feel screwed
and
we're also
angry that this is an obvious political
ploy when this presidency from an
economic standpoint is the greatest
failure since jimmy carter
we have the highest inflation the gas
pump will make you puke
your fill up your buggy at the grocery
store it'll make you puke your interest
rates on your homes are up the housing
market has slowed down we're in a
recession
we are we may be we were the last two
quarters we were in a session where we
may be recovering from a light recession
it's not much of a recession but it's a
recession which by god the economy is
not prospering
oh and they just passed the largest
spending bill in
history to add to this and this uh move
of the stroke of a pen of ten thousand
dollar forgiveness amounts to about 300
billion
with a b
more
debt
so you people listening just paid off
all these other people's student loan
debt
and your grandkids paid them off
and so while we are happy for you
individuals and we are this slide
towards socialism with this extreme left
wing nuts
is it's out of control
it's completely out of control this is a
failed presidency the the democrats are
going to have a bloodbath at the
midterms they're going to get thrown out
like no other party's ever been thrown
out and you can go and mark that word
down and if i'm wrong i'll come back and
say i was wrong like i did a minute ago
but if i'm right i'm going to say i told
you so too
but it's coming
americans are sick of the wackiness
coming out of the island the misfit toys
known as washington dc
they are sick of it
and they're going to fire a bunch of
people's butts with a d after their name
and this guy this little move right here
is not going to save it it's not going
to keep that from happening because
everybody's pretty aware that when you
walk up to a gas pump and there's a
sticker on it with a biden that says i
did that and you're looking at your gas
you know i filled up my truck i had you
know when they cut it off at 100
you have to do it again
because the con so i'm like oh i'm
running my my debit card in there in and
out you know people know what's going on
in the midst of this right just so you
know before we went on the air i was
like hey as we talk about this
let's do like a book about the american
and a little bit about the about about
political because here's the deal
regardless of who it is
that's the only reason it happened it is
but regardless of who gets in in
november that's not going to change your
life people listening like no it's not
going to change
and who's in washington dc they're all
an island of misfit toys and if you want
to change your life
you have to believe in the power of
yourself and that you can do it
absolutely and you also also ought to
call your congressman and tell them
you're going to fire them because they
continue to make student loans
that too
so what about the guy who takes out
student loans next week
what are you going to do to help him
you you bozos keep making these loans
but they're so bad you have to forgive
them because americans are being
oppressed by you
this is talking out of both sides of
your mouth just so intellectually
dishonest if you're so bad you have to
cancel them why are you continuing to
make them you should at least stop
making them before we start
start forgiving them
it's just intellectually dishonest and
it's it's an obvious political it is yes
it's a ploy yes it was a campaign
promise for a year and a half you've
been in office why did it take you a
year and a half if i make a promise i
don't have to wait a year and a half to
fulfill it i can just do it it's just
like that god this is aggravating
well and it's just the whole industry
though cause the whole industry is so
predatory so predatory and he's 18 year
olds you can't buy beer but you can go a
hundred thousand dollars in debt yeah
it's just dumber than crap well and the
people that and these kids too that like
that's that's the part of your first
the first part of what you were saying
of the individuals that are happy
because this whole thing is it is so
pretty like student loans it it is this
lie that has been accepted so stop it so
those of you that have your loans
forgiven we're happy for you
the rest of you we're pissed off as you
are
because you got to pay the bill
and nobody asked you if you wanted to
pay the bill
you just got told you're going to pay
the bill
that's not nice
it's bad politics the timing is
obviously politics